covert 19 is surging in florida
a nice court there's a group of people
just dancing on the road
but it's not stopped this people holding
big parties spilling onto the streets
in osceola county
close exposed and
undeterred
in a state where gatherings are meant to
be limited
to 10 people they're doing fireworks at
us
we're on the road with the local police
[Music]
they say there's been more than 670
noise complaints
since mid-march during the covet with
all the hotels started closing down when
the theme park started shutting down
we started noticing where people have
been
[Music]
renting houses hundreds of people will
actually come down
to these houses and pretty much they get
out of control
no evidence of anyone intentionally
exposing themselves to the virus
it looks more like frustrated people in
search of fun
but it comes with risk they're not
wearing face coverings
they're intermingling with one another
some of them are falling down drunk
they don't have any regard for anybody
else
they're just seemingly living for the
moment
a lot of these houses are vacation homes
uh
short-term rentals do you know how much
people are charging to attend these
classes
heard they charge anywhere from 40 50 60
a ticket so you can see people start
gathering
so you see the movement that we're
having yeah so that this is a
possibility we're gonna have a party
around this area
many of the owners of these homes live
abroad
have you seen a car a large car going to
one place a lot of cars
that's what i'm about to give you okay
tonight
they are everywhere what we're doing
we try we're trying to saturate the area
and the crackdown is working because of
the enforcement action that we've taken
they already have canceled four parties
there aren't big numbers on the streets
but there are
inside the houses it's two o'clock in
the morning and there's still
big groups very few people wearing masks
and
there's nothing the police can do
some on holiday here sound just as
worried as the police
do you think people are sort of
deliberately ignoring the rules yes
they don't care they don't care they
don't they're selfish it's florida
it's important it's what it's for we
don't care if they want a party they
don't have it
the land of the free has struggled with
the constraints of coronavirus
the next few months will be a huge test
of its patience
and prudence cordelia lynch sky
news osceola county florida